yeah I think so hey everybody thanks for
coming
so I'm Cory Bahama and I work for your
pace as the data scientist so your place
is an online mortgage loan platform so
it means I get to play a lot with
mortgage loan data but also house price
data so in this talk I will talk about
how to do Bayesian workflow wisp I'm
seen hours but before we get into the
stats now the code let me talk a bit
about the problem so anybody here they
would like to buy a house in Berlin
anyone yeah phew not so many okay so I
definitely would like to buy a house but
I'm not sure if I have the money I think
if you would have the money you probably
ought to buy one right so because I
thought well I have all this day so
about Heights prior house prices why not
check how expensive the different areas
are in Berlin which one is maybe the
most expensive one isn't maybe an area
that I could afford that is maybe bit
wrong bit cheaper so one way to approach
this model or this problem is to say
okay I'm gonna use a pretty make a
prediction problem out of it like
predict how expensive the houses and a
good way to predict the house price is
to start with its size the more
expensive a house other you can bigger a
house is of course more expensive it's
gonna be so here we have the price
whether it's the living area and to my
eye I think well you could say well it
looks a bit linear so maybe you could
get away with doing a simple model the
only problem is that we have a very huge
spread especially in the larger heart
for the larger houses if you look at
some neighborhoods so this one is Prince
lower back it's well very expensive area
to be consider like one of the most
expensive one in Berlin as you can see
here and if you come bare then this
neighborhood with for example Spandau
one no it's very much in the west of
Berlin I think many people wouldn't even
consider to still be part of Berlin and
Rondo is much cheaper compared to
Prenzlauer Berg so this seems to explain
a bit of the spread and if you look at
these two examples you could easily
imagine to fit two different linear
models to these things and it looks like
these would give like a relatively good
fit
so one idea would be to say like okay
let's fit a linear model to each
different zip code but here the problem
is that for some area some zip code like
this one in China back for some reason
we only have was three observation for
the zip code if we fit a linear model to
this three observations suddenly house
prices get cheaper the larger they are
which is nice but not very plausible so
for these three observation we would
prefer the linear model or the
prediction to be closer to our general
model of the total data and this is
basically the idea behind the
hierarchical model that also called and
mention his talk so I think your
hierarchical models are one of the
reasons why I'm quite excited about
Bayesian models I think everybody's
talking about bei like big data but most
of the time are meant very often we
still have big data but then if you look
down in the groups it's somehow more
collection of small data so so this like
the Bayesian part is very good in taking
part of the small data aspect and the
hierarchical approach then also takes
care of like exploiting this group
structure that you get in your data so
let me show you bit the math behind the
replica model I hope you are familiar or
you've seen this at some point before so
this is basic linear model Y here is the
price of a house and it's normally
distributed around some mean mu and mu
is our linear part of the smaller where
we have alpha the intercept and betters
our slope parameter for the living area
to make this more Bayesian we then just
add some priors for alpha better and
Sigma to make this model than a rockier
model we need to make a few changes to
this linear part so now we say that for
each zip code we fit one alpha parameter
and one better parameter so basically
for each of the code we fit one linear
model but then in our prior distribution
we say that our for each like each of
these alpha and better parameters they
all come from a common distribution
around a common mean moon so
this means that than these ups in these
areas where we only had three
observations they stick very close to
this over our common mean mean so that
they don't drive like they don't get
like too far away from this common
common mean so then again like we put
price on all of these hyper parameters
we now have few more parameters but
basically the changes are the one that
there are parents so yeah next is the
part to get this model into PI M C so
into Python so for this I'm using prime
c3 and I'm going to start with coding
the linear model so the linear model is
relatively easy to extend to the in an
Iraqi model so he will see a lot of code
and a lot of formulas so I'm going to
walk you through this like step by step
in the model description we start with
our Y it's normally dislike this Y or
description and I prefer to have the Y
at the top like this is the parameter
that we want to predict so in some sense
it's most important one that I want to
start with but in Python of course we
have to first declare all the other
variables that we're going to use so we
have to put it at the bottom also in the
model description it's kind of implicit
that this is the variable that we
actually observed and then in person of
course we have to make this explicit and
the next part is our linear part and
this is very much the same as small
description so the code is yeah very
pretty much the same here area comes
from a panda's data frame but you can
also use numpy array c and then we have
to declare the prior parameters and this
again also is very similar to how you
would write down the model the only okay
the only thing that's bit different is
that in time C you have to declare the
the name of the variable twice so now if
you want to extend this model to the
hierarchical model I'm just going to
focus off the few changes we need to
make you because most of the code
actually going to stay the same so we
need to make some changes to this linear
model and so now we're going to use an
index variable for our alpha and our
better parameter so this index parameter
again comes from pandas dataframe and it
needs to be integer so zip codes and
Germany looks slightly like integers but
they're actually strings
so you have to map the zip codes to an
integer variable and then for them for
the priors we also have to declare the
shape so in this model iteration we
don't say like how many zip codes we
actually have but times he needs to know
how many often better parameters it
needs to fit so we tell it like how many
sub codes now in our data and then again
the price are very much the same just
you have to repeat the code a few more
times so yeah I've been talking about
prize and I remember when I started
doing Bayesian methods I always follow
like prior decoration a bit it's a
charity like people just which throws
priors at you with some parameters but I
find it difficult to say like okay how
what kind of try actually fits for my
problem so I want to show you the like
one way that I find much easier to think
about if the plier fits with my model so
here I'm gonna concentrate on the models
for the linear model but they are
actually very much the same as for the
hierarchical model because in the right
hand you just extend this ones so we can
fit our sample from this prior using the
prime C model so this means that first
we just sample data from these three
probability distributions but then it
also inputs this data into into this
model and gives us prediction using
justice prior distributions and so here
we can just plot these prior
distributions and these priors are
so-called flat priors if you compare
these probabilities version deserve
standard normal distribution you can see
why they're called flat so they do spend
very wide range of the real line but if
a prior is flat or not actually depends
also a lot about the scale of our data
so I standardized my data me at the at
the living area which means that the
intercept represents the price of an
average sized house I divided the price
per hundred thousand just to have bit
lower numbers so that means the price is
always in a hundred thousand euros and
then the better parameter is surprise
change in hundred thousand euros per
standard deviation and then the Sigma is
our price spread like how far does price
spreads from this linear model
we have and if you then compare these
scale of this was our probability
distribution you can see that it really
covers quite right range of values so
the best thing is to actually put this
into linear Mon and select okay if you
have this prior what kind of linear
models would we expect so this is in the
result and I think it's best to think if
you give it some reference values so
here on the top line the in dark blue is
most expensive flat salt in Berlin at 8
million in the last couple of years and
then in orange the lower one is the zero
for zero
Europe and you can see that this kind of
price put a lot of probability mass on
values where we can say these are not
plausible values like most likely we
wouldn't see this data that goes above a
million years we probably wouldn't even
see much data that goes above two
million years and especially not with
like a living area of less than three
hundred square meters also I probably
shouldn't be below zero because houses
are usually expensive and have a
positive price so a better way to do
prize is to use so-called really
informative priors so in weekly
informative prize we try to capture this
range of data that we think is plausible
but we still try to not be too
informative like to go into one value
but to really just give like just give
them more like okay this is the kind of
range of values that we expect so if we
then compare this one with the prior we
had before you can see it's much more
informative but if you then also check
the small you can still see that there's
a lot of range a variety like how this
model can change and then also learn
from the data so now most of our model
is like below this our most expensive
flat we still have many more like still
many values that are below zero so this
is maybe something you could improve and
we also still have many lines that have
a negative slope which we also know from
our domain knowledge is not possible so
if you want to be even more informative
it could also be possible to make this
price even more informative and give
them this knowledge say like okay better
has to be positive and also alpha is
also positive
but for most cases these weekly
informative fires already work very well
so I'm just gonna go to visit them so
now he's decided on price we can then
sample from our model in this case I
think it didn't took too long so maybe
less than two minutes so at least for
this data was quite fast so before we
can then use our model we have to check
if it actually converged or not so to
check if the model converges I'm going
to use the package office which gives
many convenient functions to plot the
model it set right to for these
conversion statistics so a good thing to
start when checking a verbatim all
converged is to check these trace plots
so here you can see the trace plots for
this common mean parameters and these
tri spots outside look pretty good if
you're not sure what to look for if when
a trace for looks good let me show you a
few examples so this was one example
where I miss coded something in the
model and there are a few things that
you really do not want to see in your
tri spots so first there are some well
on the left you see that there like some
how to you mode so it didn't it doesn't
look like these two chains converge to
the same parameter and then also here in
the trace file you can see some very
weird patterns and you don't want to see
any patterns or wheat patterns in your
choice plot at all it should look super
random and another thing is these are
black ragged lines so this is prime C
telling you that there were divergences
in your model if you have any
divergencies this is really bad and you
should check what happens and should be
concerned this says that actually they
work divergencies at almost every step
of my model so if something's really
really bad and you should not use this
in this case time C usually also tells
it's like to not use the result some
things that happened and yeah so in this
case yeah if this happens go back to
your code and check if there's some
coding mistake et cetera so this was a
different model and it looks much better
than the one above it still has a few
divergences here so this is stuff is the
reason for concern and to not use this
data but already the try spots look look
much better like they don't have this
very
patterns but they also still look like
they had some troubles to convert like
you see that there's still a lot of
autocorrelation it's not very tiny part
but in this case often it's enough to
just change video sampling parameters so
that like maybe let the tuning run for
longer sometimes they usually also
taught see what kind of parameters you
could try if this happened so that
improves and in that case it's very
possible to go from the small above to
one that fits quite well so but the
problem is that I have one F parameter
and one better parameter for each zip
code and in Berlin we have more than
hundreds of codes so in total my model
Heights are more than 400 parameters so
that means we can't really look at each
trice plot so in this case there are a
few summary diagnostic statistics that
we can look at to check if there are any
problems so the first one is the Monte
Carlo standard error the Monte Carlo
standard error types like how good the
posterior mean is how about the center
line what the standard error is the next
one is the estimate the effective sample
size and so as you can see before the
trace pods like they have
autocorrelation so that actually means
that your sample you get in the end from
your posterior it's not the same
independent emphasize number from from
the s the size of your sample so because
of this articulation yet it's not a
completely independent sample and there
are some ways to estimate how how
effective this sample sizes that you
have and then the last one is our head
that I had statistics you check if all
the chains the different chains you have
converged to the same distribution so
this should be very close to one so then
we can plot a histogram the yeah all
these freedom statistics for all our
chatter for all our parameters and for
the Monte Carlo standard error it should
be below like 10% of your posterior
standard deviation here we can see that
it's all below 2% so that looks fine the
effective sample size should be at least
greater than 10% of the
number of iterations that you have and
you also yeah this is all above that
line and our heads autistic should be at
least smaller than 105 many people are
saying it probably even better to be
booked below one or one and here's all
below one or service so that's all
pretty fine
so in this race we can say okay probably
the small converged I don't see any
obvious problems and we can check how
good this model actually fits our data
so for this I'm using the sound like the
posterior predictive so because we don't
actually get a point estimate from our
models but like a whole distribution
it's you cannot like straightforwardly
use the same approach as for standard
machine learning where you just could
check the accuracy because you actually
have a distribution to check so one way
is to then check the distribution and
compare the distribution of your
observed data with the posterior
predictive distribution so here I
sampled three three samples for my
posterior predictive and compare them
with the observed data in the left and
you can see that the possible
distribution look very similar but
there's one problem that our observed
data does not go below zero but our
posterior things our model thinks that
this is possible so this is basically
the same approach just like slightly was
like if this differently so now you can
have compare the x-axis a bit better and
again we see the same problem our
observed data this one here does not go
below zero but the facility samples from
our procedure predictive I think this is
possible so if you would want to improve
this more this is definitely a good step
to start yeah another thing is them to
compare okay the average from our
posterior mean with our actual observed
data and ideally this should be close to
the diagonal line we can see that for
the lower house prices they are
relatively close they do look here like
their bit more below so that our model
overestimates the price but we can see
that especially for the larger for the
more expensive houses the spread widens
and it looks a bit like here the the
house prices are actually underestimated
by the model so I hope I know you're
curious to know okay how expensive are
houses in Berlin so because we put used
a relatively simple model we can use
that the intercept represents the ever
the hot the price of an average sized
house an average sized house and
burnings want hundred square meters and
we now have one intercept for each zip
code so it's relatively easy to plot
this and track okay what is surprise
estimated by our model 401 square meter
home for each zip code so there are two
zip codes where we don't have any data
and we can see that everything here in
central Berlin is very expensive so it
starts around four hundred thousand
years for this kind of home and yeah
it's get some of them alike up to five
hundred fifty thousand years also the
Southwest is a bit more expensive if
you're not from burning this area is
very famous for all its villas and
rather expensive large houses and then
the other areas round a bit cheaper so
now that I think about the yeah the
Bayesian approach is that we get a
deserve a distribution back for our
prediction so if you want to say okay
let's look for a hundred square meter
home in one or two forty three which is
the area of this conference when you we
dig it not just like one point estimate
back but a whole distribution saying
like okay most likely it's somewhere
between 300,000 and 600,000 years and
then with this distribution it's not
very easy to answer questions such as
what is the probability that the price
of such a house is below 300 thousand
euro and unfortunately this probability
is rather low with 16% and then we can
do you take this a step further and say
like okay what is the probability to
find such a home in each zip code and
then plot the probability to find a
hundred square meter home that is below
350 thousand euros and unfortunately in
this yeah I mean it's very similar to
what you saw before
prices so anywhere here this probability
is very low here too and then around
here it matter
so like the outer skirts are cheaper
yeah so that's already have getting to
the end of my model of my talk what
could you do next so of course we would
like to improve this model this is a
relatively simple start a good thing to
do always in data science odds invasion
modeling is to iterate it to it on your
prize iterate on your model it is a
traitor cetera if you want to improve
the model I think a good way to start is
to include a few more predictors I want
to use the living area but you can of
course includes the year of construction
this is very important predictor also
what kind of house is it it was actually
a flat or is it a house doesn't have God
nothing to have a balcony it is a try to
cetera then what you could also do is to
add a few more hierarchies so I used the
zip code as a hierarchy but you could
easily imagine like ok let's add another
hierarchies where zip codes that are
close to each other form one
neighborhood and then if you have more
zip codes together you have a bigger
this triggered etc and one way for them
for the kids to do this is to just use
the first three or two letters of your
zip code saying ok all that have the
same first 3 letters belong to another
hurricane if it has the same two zip
codes belongs to a district and then you
could also add group predictors so we
had can't falsify the predictor for the
percentage of green areas in a zip code
or for the district we could add for
example economical indices that are
available for this this area also so I
think this is a huge benefit of this
Bayesian model approach you can have
very flexible models like adding more
hierarchies mop read a group selected
etc you can also try different
likelihoods so you already saw that the
model saw the prices could grow below
zero because I used normal likelihood
but you could also use a lock normal
likelihood or also for example robust
like user make hurt a rust model by
using a student T distribution so this
would make it more robust to what's out
lies and this data does have
a few outliers and I guess if you want
to buy a house you maybe need to save
with more money all right so yeah if you
initially invaded modeling these are a
few resources that we can recommend some
of them are many of them are for Stan
but especially for the statistical
rethinking there's also a port 2 prime C
so these are definitely good with us to
check out if you're from Berlin I'm also
organizing the bird invasion need F so
feel free to pop by if you're interested
in that welcome to come and yeah that's
it thank you very much Thank You Corey
questions thank you for the talk I have
maybe a rather specific question like
what you said at the very end you said
if you use a log likelihood it wouldn't
go into the negative domain but I was
thinking it goes into the negative
domain because debaters are also in the
negative domain so that's where you have
a negative crisis both of course you
could have if you could have a normal
likelihood and if then you alpha and you
better are both positive she will not
get negative for that but if you have a
lot of likelihood this does not matter
like a knock normal likelihood so then
the prices have to be positive by
reinforce it through the model it's
basically the same as like predicting
the lock fries instead of the price high
what's the reason you use darvis over
the like yeah visualization are offered
by PI MC so obvious is actually not a
partner package of prime C so I think
the visualizations in Pine C actually
using iris I'm not even sure but it
offers more visualizations but also some
of the visualizations I did myself
because I could not find them in the
iris package so you had this one slide
where there were like reasons why a
model was good something about an R
value being less than
1.05 I often see lots of these
statistics I'm you know I'm yeah I've
done some math but one thing that always
evaporates in my mind is what's the
intuition behind some of these things do
you know of a good resource way that
sort of the intuitions explain a bit
more yeah so I do so uploaded all the
code for this notebooks and in from
their notebooks are actually wrote down
like some of the like links to resource
it explained or maybe not too much of
the intuition but a bit of the math and
intuition behind the eye height and the
other three parameters I mean I think
the eye height is relatively intuitive
you have the chain and do you want them
to be very similar but yeah I can
recommend you like I put the links in
the notebooks where can we find the
notebooks I'm gonna say yeah it's one
gets hot but I'm not gonna upload it I
know what we did some well some more
questions yeah thank you for the talk
maybe we provoked it a question why not
just to strip out the latitude and
longitude from the zip codes using the
shapefiles and then just use the Gojira
geographically weighted regression so I
didn't use the last night too because I
didn't have in my data so when I was
working on this data for many of the
houses I only had two the code I didn't
have the address for Animas ation
reasons etcetera and I'd say I think
then this zip code approach works well I
guess like what you could do if you only
have the zip code you could use the mean
of the zip code last two longitude yeah
it doesn't seem like you really yes so
but then you would have yes I mean the
code is indeed it's not very precise and
also many zip codes are very
heterogeneous way but I think one thing
that I dislike about this approach is
for some
observations you will have exact
latitude longitude address and then for
some not so you would have many
observations that have the same Leslie
longitude like for other observations
where you don't have the exact address
and that does not seem like a super nice
approach to me I'm interested how fast
it works how many houses you had in your
data set and how how long does it take
to to create a model okay so this later
said uses around a heads around 9,000
observations and I wanted to time it but
yeah I didn't but it was very quick so
yes I think it was less than 2 minutes
for the hierarchical model ok we have
time for some more questions that come
to you yeah thank you for your talk did
you try to run your experiments with
generalized linear model with mixed
effects on the zip code because if you
stay only with Gaussian distributions I
expect the result to be yeah basically
it's the same I'm not sure I got this
you say if I try out generalized linear
model I was mixed effects on the zip
code but that's what I did
yeah yeah exactly that's what you did
but why did you use EMC framework
because you can optimize that without so
a Monte Carlo sampling from I am seeing
you mean like instead of using Bayesian
approach to he's what so I mean one
reason was also that I want to try out
this approach but the other I think
would be because of this so I what I
read was there was a frequentist
approach she don't always get the best
convergence ease and especially if the
model gets more complex they run into
problems that they don't converge and I
think that the Bayesian approach also
has the advantage that then you can have
this this probability of yeah I'm not
going to go through back so that's this
probability distribution of your results
so I think this is stuff nyan bonus
okay last question and then we go for
lunch just a curiosity to compare your
results with variational based methods
to give you similar results so if
there's no I did not okay then let's
thank Corey again
[Applause]